uh
do you think there's a meaning or reason
to any of this
this existence this life well we we make
our own meaning
for sure i find a huge amount of meaning
in what i do
i find it beautiful i feel very lucky
and blessed to be in the line of work
that i'm in
you know to have your hobby and your
passion and your job just be a
completely integrated thing
so that's where i find meaning but
you're just a bag of like
cells and bacteria that eventually
dissipates dies and it goes into the
ground
and disappears back into the universe
i mean that doesn't make any sense well
that may be true but
uh i find the sublime in things like
bitcoin i find it incredibly inspiring
to work on it
i believe it's a hundred year plus
project
and uh you know it stirs those aesthetic
emotions in you as i'm sure your work
does
so you find it beautiful absolutely
absolutely
and and inspiring more than just
beautiful do you have hope for human
civilization
and bitcoin is part of that hope yeah
it's a very optimistic view
and people accuse us of being pessimists
and saying that we are you know rooting
for the collapse of civilization
completely false um bitcoiners
are compl are wildly optimistic because
they believe that you can monetize a
completely new system from scratch
and compete with the strongest
superpower in the military in the dollar
and
everything that goes with that that's
the craziest
most ludicrously optimistic proposition
imaginable
so i think bitcoiners are the most
optimistic people out there
i don't think there's a better way to
end it on that hopeful
vision of human civilization nick i've
heard
a lot of amazing things about you i was
binge watching your interviews binge
reading
your blogs fell in love with your work
you're a good dude uh inspiring
brilliant
thank you so much for wasting all your
valuable time with me today
my absolute pleasure
you